[Music]
whatever you're thinking it's not that
matching white cowboy hats platinum
blonde hair and pink paisley scarves
ryan and margo are rocking western theme
ken and barbie on set in la margot
serving up a retro twist with these
glittering starry bell bottoms ryan's
longtime love eva mendes is all in she
posted this pic of ripped ryan in
character and wrote hashtag that's my
kin
ryan's co-star marvel cimu liu told us
he had to step up his gym game who
worked out harder definitely ryan i'm
gonna 100 he's he's definitely like a
gym in the morning gym after work kind
of guy and i just love
food
a lot
what can we expect from the movie i feel
like the less i tell you the better just
fun just fun colors like we're wearing
bright vibrant fun celebration i feel
like july of next year when it comes
people are going to be really really
surprised one plot theory well from the
picks the barbies appear to be living
like fish out of water trying to manage
life in the mundane human world
barbie also stars will ferrell issa rae
and kate mckinnon
now let's go from la to athens where
shooting is underway right now on
another big movie my big fat greek
wedding three and guess who the director
is it's me
i'm not finished telling that story
we take our first steps as husband and
wife
that's nia vardalis reuniting with her
on-screen husband john corbett this time
around the story reportedly focuses on
their daughter's upcoming ideas i'm in a
little room getting ready to go down and
film i think my bras back there i'll
show you part of it
we're filming in the beautiful placa of
athens
from an on-screen wedding to a real-life
split let's move on to couples news
media mogul rupert murdoch and former
supermodel jerry hall are reportedly
calling it quits after six years
together he's 91 she's 65. it's the
fourth and shortest marriage for the
billionaire as for their settlement well
it's unclear if jerry signed a prenup
she split from mick jagger in 1999. mrs
mick jagger here and i've got the ring
to prove it jerry walked away with about
15 million dollars after that breakup
murdoch's fortune is estimated to be
worth 20 billion dollars
[Music]